The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I guess [OBSCURED]
Let's get going.
OK, should I introduce you?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: If you want.
I can introduce myself.
PROFESSOR: We have Bradley
Kuszmaul who's been doing
articles on Cilk?
He's a very interesting
paralleling and also what you
can say about the program It's
a very interesting project
that coming for a while, and
there's a lot of interesting
things he's developed,
and multi core
becoming very important.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So how
many of you people have
ever heard of Cilk?
Have used it?
So those of you who have
used it may find
this talk old or whatever.
So Cilk is a system that
runs on a shared-memory
multiprocessor.
So this is not like the system
you've been programming for
this class.
This kind of machine you have
processors, which each have
cache and some sort of a network
and a bunch of memory
and when the processors do
memory operations they are all
on the same address space
and it's typically--
the memory system provides some
sort of coherence like
strong consistency or maybe
released consistency.
We're interested in the case
where the distance from
processors to other processors
into a processors to memory
may be nonuniform and so it's
important to use the cache
well in this kind of machine
because you can't
just ignore the cache.
So sort of the technology that
I'm going to talk about for
this kind of system
is called Cilk.
Cilk is a C language and it does
dynamic multithreading
and it has a provably
good runtime system.
So I'll talk about what
those all mean.
Cilk runs on shared-memory
machines like Suns and SGIs
and well, you probably can't
find Alphaservers anymore.
It runs on SMPs like that are
in everybody's laptops now.
There's been several interesting
applications
written in Cilk including virus
shell assembly, graphics
rendering, n-body simulation.
We did a bunch of chess programs
because they were
sort of the raison
d'etre for Cilk.
One of the features about Cilk
is that it automatically
manages a lot of the
low-level issues.
You don't have to do load
balancing, you don't have to
write in protocols.
You basically write programs
that look a lot more like the
ordinary Cilk programs instead
of saying first I'm going to
do this and then I'm going to
set this variable and then
somebody else is going to read
that variable and that's a
protocol and those are very
difficult to get right.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yeah,
I'll mention that
a little bit later.
We had award-winning
chess player.
So to explain what Cilk's about
I'll talk about Fibonacci.
Now Fibonacci, this is just to
review in case you don't know
C. You all know C right?
So Fibonacci is the function
that each number is the sum of
the previous two Fibonacci
numbers.
And this is an implementation
that basically does that
computation directly.
The Fibonacci of n if n is
less than 2, it's just n.
So Fibonacci of zero
is zero, 1 is 1.
2, the Fibonacci's--
well, then you have to do the
recursion, so you compute
Fibonacci of n minus 1 and
Fibonacci of n minus 2 and sum
them together and that's
Fibonacci of n.
One observation about this
function is it's a really slow
implementation of Fibonacci.
You all know how to
do this faster?
How fast can you do Fibonacci?
You all know this, How
fast is this one?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So for those
of you who don't know--
certainly know how to compute
Fibonacci in linear time just
by keeping track of the
most recent two.
1, 1, 2, 3, 5, you just do it.
This is exponential time and
there's an algorithm that does
it in logarithmic time.
So this implementation is
doubly, exponentially bad.
But it's good as a didactic
example because it's easy to
understand.
So to turn this into Cilk we
just add some key words and
I'll talk about what the key
words are in a minute, but the
key thing to understand about
this is if you delete the key
words you have a C program and
Cilk programs have the
property that one of the legal
semantics for the Cilk program
is the C program that you get
by deleting the key words.
Now there's other possible
semantics
you could get because--
not for this function, this
function always produces the
same answer because there's
no race conditions in it.
But for programs that have
races you may have other
semantics that the system
could provide.
And so this kind of a language
extension where you can sort
of delete the extensions and get
a correct implementation
of the parallel program is
called a faithful extension.
A lot of languages like OpenMP
have properties that if you
had these directives and if
you delete them, it will
change the semantics of your
program and so you have to be
very careful.
Now if you're careful about
programming OpenMP you can
make it so that it's faithful,
that has this property.
But that's not always
the case that it is.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Is it built
on the different..
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: C 77.
No, C 89.
AUDIENCE: OK, so there's
no presumption
or any alias involved?
It's assumed that
the [OBSCURED].
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So the
issue of restricted
pointers, for example?
AUDIENCE: Restricted pointers.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So Cilk
turns out to work
with C 99 as well.
AUDIENCE: But is the presumption
though for a
pointer that it could alias?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: The Cilk
compiler makes no assumptions
about that.
If you write a program
and the back end--
Cilk works and I'll talk about
this in a couple minutes.
Cilk works by transforming
this into a C
program that has--
when you run it on one processor
it's just the
original C program in effect.
And so if you have a dialect
of C that has restricted
pointers and a compiler that--
PROFESSOR: You're taking
the assumptions that
if you make a mistake--
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: If you make a
mistake the language doens't
stop you from making
the mistake.
AUDIENCE: Well, but in C 89
there's not a mistake.
There's no assumption about
aliasing, right?
It could alias.
So if I said --
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Because of
the aliasing you write a
program that has a race
condition in it, which is
erroneous--
AUDIENCE: It would be valid?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: No,
it'd still be valid.
It would just have a race in
it and you would have a
non-determinate result.
PROFESSOR: It may not
do what you want.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: It may not do
what you want, but one of
the legal executions of that
parallel program is the
original C program.
AUDIENCE: So there's no extra.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: At the sort
of level of doing analysis,
Cilk doesn't do analysis.
Cilk is a compiler that compiles
this language and the
semantics are what they are,
which is you the spawn is
its-- and I'll talk about
the semantics.
The spawn means you can run the
function in parallel and
if that doesn't give you the
same answer every time it's
not the compilers fault.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: There has to be some
guarantee [OBSCURED].
[OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: How in a race
condition you get some
[OBSCURED].
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: One of the
legal things the Cilk system
could do is just run this,
run that program.
Now if you're running it on
multiple processors that's not
what happens because the other
thing is there's some
performance guarantees we get.
So there's actually
parallelism.
But on one processor in fact,
that's exactly what the
execution does.
So Cilk does dynamic
multithreading and this is
different from p threads for
example where you have this
very heavyweight thread that
costs tens of thousands of
instructions to create.
Cilk threads are really small,
so in this program there's a
Cilk thread that runs basically
from when the fib
starts to here and then--
I feel like there's a missing
slide in here.
I didn't tell you about spawn.
OK, well let me tell you about
spawn because what the spawn
means is that this function
can run in parallel.
That's very simple.
What the sync means is that all
the functions that were
spawned off in this function all
have to finish before this
function can proceed.
So in a normal execution of C,
when you call a function the
parent stops.
In Cilk the parent can keep
running, so while that's
running the parent-- this can
spawn off this and then the
sync happens and now the
parent has to stop.
And this key word basically just
says that this function
can be spawned.
AUDIENCE: Is the sync in that
scope or the children scope?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: The sync is
scoped within the function.
So you could have a 4 loop
that spawned off a
whole bunch of stuff.
AUDIENCE: You could call the
function instead of moving
some spawns, but
then [OBSCURED]
in the sync.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: There's an
explicit sync at the end of
every function.
So Cilk functions are strict.
PROFESSOR: [NOISE]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: You know,
there's children down inside
here, but this function can't
return-- well, if I had
omitted the sync and down in
some leaf the compiler puts
one in before the function
returns.
There's some languages that are
like this where somehow
the intermediate function can go
away and then you can sync
directly with your
grandparent.
AUDIENCE: Otherwise
it would stop.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So this gives
you this dag, so you
have this part of the program
that runs up to the first
spawn and then part of the
program that runs between the
spawns and the part of the
program that runs after--
well, after the last spawn to
the sync and then from there
to the return.
So I've got this drawing
that shows this
function sort of running.
So first the purple code runs
at it gets to the spawn, it
spawns of this guy, but now the
second piece of code can
start running.
He does a spawn, so these two
are running in parallel.
Meanwhile.
This guy started that pff.
This is a base case, so he's
going to not do anything.
Just feels like there's
something
missing in this slide.
Oh well.
Essentially now this
guy couldn't run
going back to here.
This part of the code couldn't
run until after sync so this
thing's sitting here waiting.
So when these guys finally
return then this can run.
This guy's getting stuck here.
He runs and he runs.
These two return and the
value comes up here.
And now basically the
function is done.
One observation here is that
there's no mention of the
number of processors
in this code.
You haven't specified how
to schedule or how many
processors.
All you've specified is this
directed acyclic graph that
unfolds dynamically and it's
up to us to schedule those
onto the processors.
So this code is processor
oblivious.
It's oblivious to the number
of processors.
PROFESSOR: But because we're
using the language we're
probably have to create, write
as many spawns depending on--
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: No, what you
do is you write as many spawns
as you can.
You expose all the parallelism
in your code.
So you want this dag to have
millions of threads in it
concurrently.
And then it's up to us to
schedule that efficiently.
So it's a different mindset
then, I have 4 processors, let
me create 4 things to do.
I have 4 processors, let me
create a million things to do.
And then the Cilk scheduler
guarantees to give you-- you
have 4 processors, I'll give
you 4 fold speed up.
PROFESSOR: I guess what you'd
like to avoid is the mindset
of the programmer has to change
or find the changing
tuning the parameters
for the performance.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: There's some
tuning that you do in order to
make the leaf code.
There's some overhead for
doing function calls.
So it's small overhead.
It turns out the cost
of the spawn is like
three function calls.
If you were actually trying to
make this code run faster you
make the base case bigger and do
something, trying to speed
things up a little bit with
the leaves of this call.
So there's this call tree
and inside the call
tree is this dag.
So it supports C's rule
for pointers.
For whatever dialect you have.
If you have a pointer to a
stack and then you have a
pointer to the stack and then
you call, you're allowed to use
that pointer in C. So in
Cilk you are as well.
If you have a parallel thing
going on where normally in C
you would call A, then B
returns, then C and D. So C
and D can refer to anything on
A, but C can't legally refer
to something on B and the same
rule applies to Cilk.
So we have a data structure that
implements this cactus
stack is what it's called, after
the sugauro cactus--
the view of the imagery
there and it lets you
support that rule.
There's some advanced features
in Cilk that have to do with
speculative execution and I'm
going to skip over those today
because it turns out that sort
of 99% of the time you don't
need this stuff.
We have some debugger support,
so if you've written code that
relied on some semantics that
maybe you didn't like when you
went to the parallel world,
you'd like to find out.
This is a tool that basically
takes a Cilk program and an
input data set and it runs and
it tells you is there any
schedule that I could have
chosen-- so it's that directed
acyclic graph.
So there's a whole bunch of
possible schedules I could
have chosen.
Is there any schedule that
changes the order of two
concurrent memory operations
where one of them is right?
So we call this the
non-determinator because it
finds all the determinacy
races in your program.
And Cilk guarantees-- the Cilk
race detector is guaranteed to
find those.
There's a lot of race detectors
where if the race
doesn't actually occur you
have two things that are
logically in parallel, but if
they don't actually run on
different processors a lot of
race detectors out there in
the world won't report
the race.
So you get false negatives and
there's a bunch of false
positives that show up.
This basically only gives
you the real ones.
AUDIENCE: That might be
indicatiors there might be
still a data to arrays.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So this
doesn't analyze the program.
It analyzes the execution.
So it's not trying to solve some
MP complete problem or
Turing complete problem.
And so this reduces the problem
of finding data races
to the situation that's just
like when you're trying to do
code release and quality control
for serial programs.
You write tests.
If you don't test your program
you don't know what it does
and that's the same
property here.
If you do find some race someday
later then you can
write a test for it and know
that you're testing to make
sure that race didn't creep
back into your code.
That's what you want out of a
software release strategy.
AUDIENCE: [NOISE]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: If you start
putting in sync than maybe the
race goes away because
of that.
But if just put in
instrumentation to try to
figure out what's going,
it's still there.
And the race detector sort of
says, this variable in this
function, this variable in this
function, you look at it
and say, how could
that happen?
And finally you figured out and
you fix it and then you
put it-- if you're trying to do
software release you build
a regression test that will
verify that has that input.
AUDIENCE: What if you have a
situation where the spawn
graph falls into a terminal.
So it's not a radius, but
monitoring spawn is there but
it spawns a graph a
little bit deeper.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yes.
For example, our race detector
understands locks.
So part of the rule is it
doesn't report a race if the
two memory accesses--
if there was a lock that they
both held in common.
Now you now you can write buggy
programs because you can
essentially do the memory at
lock, you know, read the
memory, unlock, lock,
write the memory.
Now the interleave happens
and there's a race.
So the assumption of this race
detector is that if you put
locks in there that you've
sort of thought about.
This is finding races that you
forgot about rather than races
that you ostensibly
thought about.
There are some races that
are actually correct.
For example, in the chess
programs there's this big
table that remembers all
the chess positions
that have been seen.
And if you don't get the right
answer out of the table it
doesn't matter because you
search it again anyway.
Not getting the right
answer means you
don't get any answer.
You look something up and it's
not there so you search again.
If you just waited a little
longer maybe somebody else
would have put the value
in, you could have
saved a little work.
And so in that case, well it
turns out to be there's no
parallel way to do that.
So I'm willing to tolerate that
race because that gives
me performance and so you have
what we call fake locks, which
are basically things that look
like lock calls, but they
don't do anything except tell
the race detector, pretend
there was a lock
held in common.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: If it says
there's no race it means that
for every possible
scheduling that--
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Well,
you have that dag.
And imagine running it
on one processor.
There's a lot of possible
orders in
which to run the dag.
And the rule is well, was there
a load in a store or a
store in a store that switched
orders in some possible
schedule and that's
the definition.
AUDIENCE: So, in practice,
sorry, one of the [INAUDIBLE]
techniques is loss.
Assuming, dependent on the
processor, that you have
atomic rights, we want to
deal with that data
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] in
the background --
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Those
protocols are really hard to
get right, but yes, it's
an important trick.
AUDIENCE: Certainly
[INAUDIBLE].
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So to convince
the race detector not
to complain you put fake
locks around it.
You've programmed a
sophisticated algorithm it's
up to you to get the
details right.
The other property about this
race detector is that it's
fast. It runs almost
in liear time.
A lot of the race detectors that
you find out there run in
quadratic time.
So if you want to run a million
instructions it has to
compare every instruction to
every other instruction.
Turns out we don't
have to do that.
We run in time, which is n times
alpha of n where alpha's
the inverse Ackermann
function.
Anybody remember that from
the union-find algorithm.
It's got that graded So it's
like the almost linear time.
We actually now have a linear
timed one that has performance
advantages.
So let me do a little
theory in practice.
In Cilk we have some fundamental
complexity
measures that we worry about.
So we're interested in knowing
and being able to predict the
runtime of a Cilk program
on P processors.
So we want to know T sub p,
which is the execution time on
P processors.
That's the goal.
What we've got to work with is
some directed acyclic graph
that is for a particular input
set and if the program
determines it and everything
else it's a well defined graph
and we can come up with some
basic measures of this graph.
So T sub 1 is the work of the
graph, which is the total time
it would take to run that
graph on one processor.
Or if you assume that these
things are all cost unit
times, just the number
of nodes.
So for this graph
what's the work?
I heard teen, but something--
18?
And the critical path
is the longest path.
And if these nodes weren't unit
time you'd have to weight
the things according
to actually how
much time they run.
So the critical path
here is what?
9.
So I think those are right.
The lower bounds then that you
know is that you don't expect
the runtime on P processes to be
faster than linear speedup.
In this model that
doesn't happen.
It turns out cache
does things.
It's adding more than
just processors.
You're adding more cache too.
So all sorts of things or maybe
it means that there's a
better algorithm you
should have used.
So there's some funny things
that happen if you have bad
algorithms and so forth.
But in this model you can't have
more than linear speedup.
You also can't get things done
faster than in linear time.
This model assumes basically
that these costs of running
these things are fixed and the
cache has the property that
changing the order of execution
means that the
actual costs of the nodes in
the graph change costs.
So those are lower bounds and
the things that we want to
know are speedups, so that's
T sub 1 over T sub p.
And the parallelism of
the graph is T sub
1 over T sub infinity.
So the work over the critical
path and we've been calling
this span sometimes lately.
Some people call that depth.
Span is easier to say than
critical path, depth has too
many other meanings so
I kind of like span.
So what's the parallelism
for this program?
18/9.
We said that T sub 1 was what?
18.
The infinity is 9.
So on average and if you had
an infinite number of
processors and you scheduled
this as greedy as you good, it
would take you 9 steps to run
and you would you be doing 18
things worth of work.
So on average there's
two things to do.
You know, 1 plus 1 plus 1 plus
3 plus 4 plus 4 plus 1 plus 1
plus 1 divided by 9
turns out to be 2.
So the average parallelism or
just the parallelism of the
program is T sub 1 over
T sub infinity.
And this property is something
that's not dependent on the
scheduler, it's a property
of the program.
Doesn't depend on how many
processors you have.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
You're saying, you're calling
that the span now?
Is that the one for
us [OBSCURED]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: That's
too long to say.
I might as well say critical
path length.
Critical path length, longest
trace span is a mathematical
sounding name.
AUDIENCE: We just like
to steal terminology.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Well, yeah.
So there's a theorem due to--
Graham and Brent said that
there's some schedule that can
actually achieve the sum of
those two lower bounds.
This linear speedup is one lower
bound of the runtime and
the critical path
is the other.
So there's some schedule that
basically achieves the sum of
those and how does that
theorem work?
Well, at each time
step either--
suppose we had 3 processors.
Either there's at least 3 things
ready to run and so
what you do is you do
a greedy schedule.
You grab any 3 of them.
If there's fewer than p things
to run, like here we have a
situation where these
have all run.
The green ones are
ready to go.
Those are the only 2 that
are ready to go.
So what do you do then
in a greedy schedule?
You run them all.
And the argument goes, well, how
many times steps could you
execute 3 things?
At most you could do it the work
divided by the number of
processors times because
then after that you've
used up all the work.
Well how many times could you
execute less than p things?
Well, every time you execute
less than p things you're
reducing the length of the
remaining critical path.
You can't do that more
than the span times.
And so a greedy scheduler will
achieve some runtime which is
within the sum of these 2.
It's actually the sum
of these 2 minus 1.
It turns out that there has to
be at least one node that's on
both work and critical path.
And so that means that you're
guaranteed to be within a
factor of 2 of optimal with
a greedy schedule.
And it turns out that if you
have a lot of parallelism
compared to the number
processors, so if you have a
graph that has a million fold
parallelism and a thousand
fold processors Well, if this
is really small compared to
the work, if you have a graph
with a million fold
parallelism that means the
critical path is small.
If you only had 1000 processors
that means this
term's big.
And that means that this term is
very close to this term, so
essentially the corollary to
this is that you get linear
speedup, perfect linear speed
asymptotically if you have
fewer processors then you have
parallelism in your program.
So the game here at this level
of understanding, I haven't
told you how the scheduler
actually works-- is to write a
program that's got a lot of
parallelism that you can get
linear speedup.
Well, the work-stealing
scheduler we actually use.
The problem is the greedy
schedulers can be hard to
compute-- especially if you
imagine having a million
processors in a program with
a billion fold parallelism.
Finding on every clock cycle,
finding something for each of
the million guys to do is
conceptually difficult, so
instead we have a work-stealing
scheduler.
I'll talk about that
in a second.
It achieves bounds which are
not quite as good as those.
This bound is the same.
It's the sum of two terms. One
is the linear speedup term,
but instead of it being T sub
infinity it's big O of T sub
infinity because you actually
have to do communication
sometimes if the critical
path length is long.
Basically, you can
sort of imagine.
If you have a lot of things to
do, a lot of tasks and people
to do it, it's easy to do that
in parallel if there's no
interdependencies
among the tasks.
But as soon as there's
dependencies you end up having
to coordinate a lot and that
communication costs--
there's lots of lore about
adding programmers to a task
and it slowing you down.
Because basically communication
gets you.
What we found empirically--
there's a theorem for this--
empirically the runtime is
actually still very close to
the sum of those terms. Or maybe
it's those terms plus 2
times T sub infinity or
something like that.
And again, we basically get
near-perfect speedup as long
as the number of processors
is a lot less than the
parallelism.
Should be sort of a less
than less than.
The compiler has the mode where
you basically can insert
instrumentations.
So you can run your program,
it'll tell you the critical
path length.
You can compute these numbers.
Clear how to compute work, you
just sum up the runtime of all
the threads.
To compute the critical path
length, well you have to do
some max's and stuff as you
go through the graph.
And the average cost of a spawn
these days is about 3 on
like a dual core pentium.
Three times the cost
of a function call.
And most of that cost actually
has to do with the memory
barrier that we do at the spawn
because that machine
doesn't have strong
consistencies.
So you have to put this memory
barrier in and that just
empties all the pipelines.
It does better on like an SGI
machine, which has strong--
well, traditional.
A MIPS machine that has strong
consistency actually does
better for the cost
of that overhead.
Let me talk a little
bit about chess.
And we had a bunch of chess
programs. I wrote one in 1994,
which placed third at the
International Computer Chess
Championship and that was
running on a big connection
machine CM5.
I was one of the architects
of that machine, so
it was double fun.
We wrote another program that
placed second in '95 and that
was running on an 1800 node
Paragon and that was a big
computer back then.
We built another program called
Cilk chess, which
placed first in '96 running on
a relatively smaller machine.
And then on a larger SGI origin
we ran some more and
then at the World Computer Chess
Championship in 1999 we
beat Deep Blue and
lost to a PC.
And people don't realize this,
but at the time that Deep Blue
beat Kasparov it was not the
World Computer Chess
Champion, a PC was.
So what?
It's running a program.
You know, there's this
head and a tape.
I don't know what it did.
So this was a program called
Fritz, which is a commercially
available program.
And those guys were very good,
the PC guys playing were very
good at getting on sort
of the algorithm side.
We got advantage
by brute force.
And we also had some real chess
expertise on our team,
but those guys were spending
full time on things like
pruning away sub-searches that
they were convinced weren't
going to pan out.
Computer chess programs spend
most of their time looking at
situations that any person would
look at and say, ah,
blacks won.
Why are you even looking
at this?
And it keeps searching.
It's like, well maybe there's
a way to get the queen.
So computers are pretty
dumb at that.
So basically these guys put a
lot more chess intelligence in
and we also lost due to what--
in this particular game, we
were tied for first place and we
decided to do a runoff game
to find out who would win and
we lost due to a classic
horizon effect.
So it turns out that we were
searching to depth 12 in the
tree and Fritz was searching
to depth 11.
Even with all these heuristics
and stuff they had in it, they
were still not searching
as deeply as we were.
But there was a move that was a
good move that looked OK at
depth 11 and looked bad at depth
11 and at depth 13 it
looked really good again.
So they saw the move and made
it for the wrong reason, we
saw the move and didn't make it
for the right reason, but
it was wrong and the right
move-- if we'd been able to
search a little deeper, we would
have seen that it was
really the wrong thing to do.
This happens all the
time in chess.
There's a little randomness
in there.
This horizon effect shows up
and again, it boils down to
the programs are not
intelligent.
A human would look at it and
say, eventually that knight's
going to fall.
But if the computer can't see
it with a search, you know?
We plotted the speedup of star
Socrates, which was the first
one on this funny graph.
So this looks sort of like a
typical linear speedup graph.
Sort of when you're down here
with few numbers processors
you get good linear speedup
and eventually you stop
getting linear speedup.
That's sort of in broad
strokes what
this graph looks like.
But the axes are
kind of funny.
The axes aren't the number of
processors and the speedup--
it's the number processors
divided by the parallelism of
the program.
And here is the speedup divided
by the parallelism of
the program.
And the reason we did that is
the each of these data points
is a different program with
different work in span.
If I'm trying to run a
particular problem on a bunch
of different processors I can
just draw that curve and see
what happens as get
more processors.
I'm not getting any advantage
because I've got too many
processors.
I've exceeded the parallelism
of the program.
But if I'm running, trying
to compare two different
programs, how do I do that?
Well, you can do that by
normalizing by the
parallelism.
So down in this domain the
number of processors is small
compared to the average
parallelism and we get good
linear speedups.
And up in this the domain the
number of processors is large
and it starts asymptoting to
the point where the speedup
approaches the parallelism and
that's sort of what happened.
You get some noise out here so
one of the things down here,
it's nice and tight.
And that's because we're in
that domain where the
communication costs are
infrequently paid because
there's lots of work to do.
You don't have to communicate
very much.
Up here there's a lot of
communication that happens and
so the noise is showing
up more in the data.
This curve here is the
T sub 1 over P plus T
sub infinity curve.
The T sub P equals T sub
infinity curve and that's the
linear speedup curve
on this graph.
So I think there's an important
lesson in this graph
besides the data itself, which
is if you're careful about
choosing the axes, you can take
a whole bunch of data
that you couldn't see how to
plot it together and you can
plot it together and get
something meaningful.
So in my Ph.D. thesis I had
hundreds of little plots for
each chess position and I didn't
figure out how-- it's
like they all look
the same, right?
But I didn't sort of figure out
that if I was careful I
could actually make
them be the same.
That happened after I
published my thesis.
Oh, we could just
overlay them.
Well, what's the normalization
that makes that work?
So there's a speedup paradox
that happened.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yeah, OK.
There was a speedup paradox that
happened while we were
developing star Socrates.
We were developing this for
512 processor connection
machine that was at University
of Illinois, but we only had a
smaller machine on which
to do our development.
We had a 128 processor machine
at MIT and most days I could
only get 32 processors
because the machine
was in heavy demand.
So we had this program
and it ran on 32
processors in 65 seconds.
And one of the developers said,
here's a variation on
the algorithm, it
changes the dag.
It's a heuristic.
It makes the program
run more efficient.
Look, it runs in only 40 seconds
on 32 processors.
And so is that a good idea?
It sure seemed like a good idea,
but we were worried that
we knew that the transformation
increased the
critical path length of the
program, so we weren't sure it
was a good idea.
So we did some calculation.
We measured the work
and the speedup.
And so the work here--
these numbers have been cooked
a little bit to make the math
easy, but the numbers--
this really did happen, but not
with these exact numbers.
So we had a work which was 2048
seconds and only 1 second
of critical path.
And over this new program had
only 1/2 as much work to do,
but the critical path
length was longer.
It was 8 seconds long.
If you predict on 32 processors
what the runtime's
going to be that formula
says well, 65 seconds.
If you predict it on 32
processors this-- well, it's
40 seconds and that looks good,
but we were going to be
running the tournament on 512
processors where this term
would start being less important
than this term.
So this really did happen and
we actually went back and
validated that these numbers
were right after we did the
calculation and it allowed us to
do the engineering to make
the right decision and not be
misled by something that
looked good in the
test environment.
We were able to predict what was
going to happen on the big
machine without actually having
access to the big
machine and that was
very important.
Let me do some algorithms. You
guys probably have done some
matrix multipliers over the
past 3 weeks, right?
That's probably the only thing
you've been able to do would
be my guess.
So matrix multiplication
is this operation.
I won't talk about it, but
you know what it is.
In Cilk instead of doing the
standard triply nested loops
you do divide and conquer.
We don't parallelize loops we
parallelize function calls, so
you want to express a
loops as recursion.
So to multipliy two big matrices
you do a whole bunch
of little matrix multiplications
of the
sub-blocks and then you express
those little matrix
multiplications themselves and
go off and recursively do
smaller matrix multiplications.
So this requires 8
multiplications of matrices
these of 1/2 the number of
rows and 1/2 the number
columns an one edition at the
end where you add these two
matrices together.
That's the algorithm that we do,
it's the same total work
as the standard one, but it's
just expressed recursively.
So a matrix multiply is you
do these 8 multiplies.
I had to create a temporary
variable, so the first four
multiplies the A's and B's
into C. The second four
multiply the A's and B's into
T and then I have to add T
into C. So I do all those
spawns, do all the multiplies.
I do a sync because I better not
start using the results on
the multiplies and adding them
until the multiplies are done.
AUDIENCE: Which four
do you add?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: What?
There's parallelism in add.
Matrix addition.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but it doesn't
add spawn extent
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Well,
we spawn off add.
I don't understand--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So you have
to spawn Cilk functions even
if you're only executing
one of them at a time.
Cilk functions are spawned,
C functions are called.
It's a decision that's built
into the language.
It's not really a fundamental
decision.
It's just that's the
way we did it.
AUDIENCE: Why'd you choose to
have the key word then?
That's just documentation
from the caller side?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Yeah, we found
we were less likely to
make a mistake if we sort of
built it into the type system
in this way.
But I'm not convinced that this
is the best way to do
this type system.
AUDIENCE: Can the C functions
spawn a Cilk function.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: No.
You can only call spawn, spawn,
spawn, spawn then you
can call C functions
at the leaves.
It turns out you can actually
spawn Cilk functions if you're
a little clever about-- there's
a mechanism for a Cilk
system running in the background
and if you're
running C you can
say OK, do this
Cilk function in parallel.
So we have that, but that's
not didactic.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I
have a question
about the sync spawning.
Is the sync actually doing a
whole wave or -- like, in the
case of-- maybe not in the case
of the add here, but in
plenty of other practical
functions you get inside the
spawn function looking
at the tendencies of
the parameters, right?
Based on how those
were built from
previous spawned funcitons.
You can actually just start
processing so long as it's
guaranteed that the results
are available before you
actually read them.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So there's
this other style of expressing
parallelism which you see
in some of the data flow
languages where you say well,
I've computed this first
multiply, why can't I get
started on the corresponding
part of the addition.
And it turns out that in those
models there's no performance
guarantees.
The real issue is you
run out of memory.
It's a long topic, let's not
go into it, but there's a
serious technical issue with
those programming models.
We have very tight memory
bounds as well, so we
simultaneously get these good
scheduling bounds and good
memory bounds and if you are
doing that you could have sort
of a really large number of
temporaries required and run
out of memory.
The data flow machine used to
have this number-- there was a
student, Ken Traub, who was
working on Monsoon when Greg
Papadapolous was here and he
came up with this term which
we called Traub's constant,
which was how long the machine
could be guaranteed to run
before it crashed from being
out of memory.
And that was-- well, he took
the rate at which it Kahn's
divided by the amount of
memory and that was it.
And many data flow programs had
that property that Monsoon
could run for 40 seconds
and then after
that you never knew.
It might start crashing at any
moment, so everybody wrote
short data flow programs.
So one of the things you
actually do when you're
implementing, when you're trying
to engineer this to go
fast, is you course in the
base case, which I didn't
describe up there.
You don't just do a 1 by 1
matrix multiplied down there
at the leaves of
this recursion.
Because then you're not using
the processor pipeline
efficiently.
You call the Intel Math Kernel
Library or something on an 8
by 8 matrix so that it really
gets the pipeline a
chance to chug away.
So analysis.
This matrix addition operation--
well, what's the
work for matrix addition?
Well the work to do a matrix
operation on n rows is well,
you have to do 4 additions
of size n over 2.
Plus there's order 1 work
here for the sync.
And that recurrence has solution
order n squared.
Well, that's not surprising.
You have to add up 2 matrices
which are n by n.
That's going to be n squared
so that's a good result.
The critical path for this is
well, you have to do all of
these in parallel.
So whatever the critical path of
the longest one is, they're
all the same so it's just the
critical path of the size n
over 2 plus quarter 1, so the
critical path is order log n.
For matrix multiplication,
sort of the reason I
do this is I can.
This is a model which I can
do this analysis, so
I have to do it.
But really, being able to do
this analysis is important
when you're trying to make
things run faster.
Matrix multiplication, well,
the work is I have to do 8
little matrix multiplies plus
I have to do the matrix add.
The work has solution order n
cubed and everybody knows that
there's order n cubed multiply
adds in a matrix multiplier,
so that's not very surprising.
The critical path is-- well, I
have to do a add so that takes
log n, plus I have to do a
multiply on a matrix that's
1/2 the size.
So the critical path length of
the whole thing has solution
order log squared n.
So the total parallelism of
matrix multiplication is the
work over the span, which is
n cubed over log squared n.
So if you have a 1000 by 1000
matrix that means your
parallelism is close
to 10 million.
There's a lot of parallelism
and in fact, we see perfect
linear speedup on matrix
multiply because there's so
much parallelism in it.
It turns out that this stack
temporary that I created so
that I could do these multiplies
all in parallel is
actually costing me work because
I'm on a machine that
has cache and I want to use
the cache effectively.
So I really don't want to create
a whole big temporary
matrix and blow my cache
out if I can avoid it.
So I proposed the following
matrix multiply, which is I
first do 4 of the matrix
multiplies into C1 then I do a
sync and then I do the other
4 into C1 and another sync.
And I forgot to do the add-- oh,
no those are multiply adds
so they're multiplying
and adding in.
And this saves space because it
doesn't need a temporary,
but it increases the
critical path.
So is that a good idea
about or a bad idea?
Well, we can answer part of that
question with analysis.
Saving space we know is going
to save something.
What does it do to the work
in critical path?
Well, the work is still the
same, it's n cubed because we
didn't change the number of
flops that we're doing.
But the critical
path has grown.
Instead of doing 1 times a
matrix multiply, we have to do
one and then sync and
then do another one.
So it's 2 matrix multiplies of
1/2 the size plus the order 1
and that recurrence has solution
order n instead of
order log squared n.
So that sounds bad, we've made
the critical path longer.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: What?
Yeah.
So parallelism is now order n
squared instead of n cubed
over log squared n and for a
1000 by 1000 matrix that means
you still have a million
fold parallelism.
So for relatively modest sized
matrices you still have plenty
of work to do this
optimization.
So this is a good transformation
to do it.
One of the advantages of Cilk
is that you can do this kind
of You could say, let me
do an optimization.
I can do an optimization in my
C code and I get to take
advantage of it in
the Cilk code.
I could do this kind of
optimization of trading work
for parallelism.
If I have a lot of work that
sometimes is a good idea.
Ordinary matrix multiplication
just is really bad.
Basically you can imagine
spawning off the n squared
inner dot products here and
computing them all in parallel.
It has work n cubed
parallelism log n.
I mean, critical path log n so
the parallelism's even better.
It's n cubed over log n
instead of n squared.
That looks better theoretically,
but it's really
bad in practice because it has
such poor cache behavior.
So we don't do that.
I'll just briefly talk
about how it works.
So Cilk does work-stealing.
We had did double ended
queue-like decque.
So at the bottom of the queue
is the stack where you push
and pop things and the top is
something where you can pop
things off if you want to.
And so what's running is all
these processors are running
each on their own stack.
They're all running the
ordinary serial code.
That's sort of the
basic situation.
They're pretty much
running the serial
code most of the time.
So some processor runs.
It pushes.
Well, it doesn't spawn,
so what does it do?
It pushes something onto its
stack because it's just a
function call.
And it does another couple more
spawns so things pop off.
Somebody returns so
he pops his stack.
So far everything's going on,
they're not communicating,
they're completely independent
computations.
This guy spawns and now
he's out of work.
Now he has to do something.
What he does is he goes and
picks another processor at
random and he steals
the thing from the
other end of the stack.
So he's unlikely to conflict
because this guy's pushing and
popping down here, but there's
a lock in there, thers's a
little algorithm.
A non-blocking algorithm
actually, it's not lock.
And so he goes and he steals
something and come on, slide
over there.
Whoa.
Yes, that's animation, right?
That's the extent
of my animation.
And then he starts
working away.
And the theorem is that a
work-stealing scheduler like
this gives expected running
time with high probability
actually of T sub 1 over P
plus T sub infinity on P
processors.
And the pseudoproof is a little
bit like the proof for
Brent's Theorem,
which is either
you're working or stealing.
If you're working well, that
goes against T sub 1 over P.
You can't do that very much
or you run out of work.
If you're stealing well, each
steal has a chance that it
steals the thing that's
on the critical path.
You may actually steal the wrong
thing, but you actually
have a 1 in P chance that you're
the one who steals the
thing that it's on the critical
path and then in
which case the expected
number--
so you had this chance of
1 over P of reducing the
critical path length by 1, so
after this many steals the
critical path is all gone.
So you can only do P times
T infinity steals.
This high probability
it comes out.
And that gives you
these bounds.
OK, I'm not going to give
you all this stuff.
Message passing sucks,
you know.
You guys know.
There's probably nothing
else in here.
So basically the pitch here is
that you get some high level
linguistics support for these
very fine-grained parallelism.
It's an algorithmic programming
model so that
means that you can do
engineering for performance.
There's fairly easy conversion
of existing code, especially
when you combine it with
the race detector.
You've got this factorization
of the debugging problem and
to debugging your serial code
is you run it with all the
Cilk stuff turned off.
You allied the program and make
sure your program works.
Then you run it with the rate
detector to make sure you get
the same answer in parallel
and then you're done.
Applications in Cilk don't just
scale to large number of
processors, they scale down
to small numbers, which is
important if you only have
two processors or one.
You don't suddenly want to pay
a factor of 10 to get off the
ground, which happens
sometimes on
clusters running MPI.
You have to pay a big
overhead before
you've made any progress.
And one of the advantages for
example is that the number of
processors might change
dynamically.
In this model that's
OK because it's
not part of the program.
So you may have the operating
system reduce the number of
actual worker threads that you
have doing that work-stealing
and that can work.
One of the bad things about
Cilk is that it doesn't
support sort of data parallel
or program model kind of
parallelism.
You really have to think of
things as this divide and
conquer kind of the world.
And if you have trouble
expressing that--
situations where you're doing
Jacobi update and you very
carefully put things on, had
each processor work on its
local memory and then they only
have to communicate at
the boundaries.
That's difficult to do right
in Cilk because essentially
every time you go around the
loop of I have all these
things to do.
All the work-stealing happens
randomly and it happens on a
different processor.
So it's not very good at that
sort of thing, although it
turns out Jacobi update's not
a very good example for that
because there are more
sophisticated algorithms that
use cache effectively that you
can express in Cilk and I
would have no idea how to no
say those in some of these
sort of data parallel
languages.
Using the cache efficiently is
really important on modern
processors.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Questions?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: You can
download Cilk, there's a bunch
of contributors.
Those are the Cilk worms
and you can download
Cilk off our webpage.
Just Google for Cilk
and you'll find it.
It's a great language,
you'll love it.
You'll love it much more than
what you've been doing.
AUDIENCE: How does the Cilk
play with processor
[OBSCURED]?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Well, you
have to have a language, a
compiler that can
generate those.
If you have an assembly command
or you have some other
complier that can
generate those.
So I just won the HPC challenge,
which is this
challenge where everybody tries
to run parallel programs
and argue that they
get productivity.
For that there were some codes
like matrix multiply and LUD
composition with pivoting.
Basically at the leads of the
computation I call the Intel
Math Kernel Library.
Which in turn uses the
SSE instructions.
You could do anything you can do
in C in the C parts of the
code because Cilk compiler just
passes those through.
So if you have some really
efficient pipeline code for
doing something, up to
some point it made
sense to use that.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So I ran
it on NASIS Columbia.
So the benchmark consists of--
well, there's 7 applications
they have. 6 of which are
actually well-defined.
One of them is this thing that
just measures network
performance or something,
so it doesn't
have any real semantics.
There's 6 benchmarks.
One of them is LUD composition,
one of them is
DJEM matrix multiplication and
this FFT and 3 others.
So I implemented all 6, nobody
else implemented all 6.
It turns out that you had to
implement 3 in order to enter.
Almost everybody implemented 3
or 4, but I did all 6 which is
part of why I won.
So I could argue that in
a weeks work I just
implemented--
AUDIENCE: What is [OBSCURED]?
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: So the prize
has two components.
Performance and productivity or
elegance or something and
it's completely whatever the
judges want that to be.
So it was up to me as a
presenter to make the case
that I was elegant.
Because I had my performance
numbers, which were pretty
good and it turned out that the
IBM entry for x10 did me
more good than I did, I think.
Because they got up there and
they compared the performance
of x10 to their Cilk
implementation and their x10
thing was almost as
good as Cilk.
So after that I think the judges
said they had to give
me the prize.
So basically, it went down to
supercomputing and each of us
got 5 minutes to present and
there were 5 finalists.
We did our presentation and
then they gave out the --
So they divided the prize three
ways: the people who got
the absolute best performance,
which were some people running
UPC and the people who had the
most elegance based on minimal
number of lines of codes and
that was Cleve at --
what's his name?
The Mathworks guy, MATLAB guy.
Who said, look, matrix,
LUD composition.
LU of P. It's very elegant,
but I don't think that it
really sort of explains what
you have to do to solve the
problems. So he won the prize
for most elegant and I got the
prize for best combination,
which they then changed--
in the final citation for the
prize they said, most
productivity.
That was the prize.
So I actually won the contest
because that was what the
contest was supposed to be
was most productivity.
But I only won 1/3 of the
prize money because they
divided it three ways.
PROFESSOR: Any other question?
Thank you.
BRADLEY KUSZMAUL: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: We'll take a 5 minute
break and since you had
guest lecturer I do
have [OBSCURED]